(bright music)
- [Narrator] Ladies and gentlemen,
this is the Thousand-hand
Bodhisattva dance.
Pretty cool, huh?
One would think that a
performance this difficult
and precise, would
require all five senses.
Well think again,
because all these dancers
can't hear the music,
making this performance even cooler.
(traditional Chinese music)
Founded in 1987, the
China Disabled Peoples'
Performing Art Troupe performs eloquent
dances, plays and operas.
(dramatic string music)
The music is performed
by the visually impaired
and the dance numbers
are performed by those hard of hearing.
The thousand hand Bodhisattva
dance is the troop's
most popular performance.
It was also one of the
most difficult dances
for them to learn.
And that's where Xiangtian comes in.
She and other instructors
use sign language
to help conduct the dancers.
(speaking in foreign language)
They also realized that spending time
together offstage, would not
only enhance their friendship,
but their performance onstage as well.
(dramatic music)
In Bin's case, he and
other musicians develop
their own technique for playing
without being able to see.
(speaking in foreign language)